science fiction has been trying to
predict the future since ancient greece
but there's one film i've always thought
seems to have accurately predicted an
uncanny amount about humanity's
direction of travel i'm not talking
about 2001 a space odyssey blade runner
or even minority report it's the
animated story of a little trash
clearing robot
i usually enjoy being right but not in
this system
i didn't want to be right on so many
things on this movie that's andrew
stanton the writer director of holly on
the surface it's a tale of two robots
falling in love on a post-apocalyptic
earth but scratch a little deeper and
there's a fable about the consequences
of consumption and technology addiction
you know the funny thing we found out
was like where do you think technology
would go and why
and what ended up being our way to
to guess that was what would seduce you
because we were watching it happen with
the phone and we were watching happening
with these electric scooters it's like
fast food you know it's bad for you but
it's just seductively too tasty and you
you cave and so we thought well
technology tends to like win out when it
hits that part of you it's the party
that likes yeah i know this probably
isn't great for my eyesight to be
staring at the screen all day but i just
need to click one more headline so it's
seduction that ended up being the
gateway into things
sticking into the culture
wally depicts a future where earth has
become inhospitable to life the extreme
weather events it portrays are already
happening with more frequency the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change determines in a recent report
that hot temperatures that used to
happen just once a decade now happen
almost every three years while droughts
are almost twice as common the film was
released just a year after the first
iphone and correctly anticipates our
burgeoning tech addictions the human
characters live a sedentary existence on
a spaceship floating around on hoverbeds
and interacting solely via video calls
us adults now spend on average more than
11 hours a day in front of a screen
in 2008 when wally was released 34
percent of u.s adults were considered
obese it's now 42 percent in
accelerating and what are they eating
the spaceman humans in wally eat meals
from a cup in recent years we've seen
the rise of firms like hule and soylent
makers of meal smoothies the meal
replacement market was worth 4.5 billion
dollars in 2008 it's now an almost 12
billion dollar
market then there are the satellites the
rocket ship in the film has to break
through a crust of them to escape
earth's orbit when the film was released
there were just a few hundred satellites
circling the earth now there are almost
eight thousand and plans to add tens of
thousands more payload
astronomers are already complaining
about their declining ability to see the
night sky
and the company that takes the humans
into space is of course also a retailer
called by and large that appears to be
something of a monopoly sounds more than
a little bit like amazon the e-commerce
giant whose sales have jumped from 19
billion dollars in 2008 to a projected
541 billion this year it hoovers up
about 40 of us e-commerce sales and
amazon founder jeff bezos also has a
space exploration company called blue
origin even in 2004 when he started
working on wally amazon was the
inspiration for stanton we were very
early adopters in our household and we
were getting boxes
you know sometimes daily uh and again
that's the norm now but at the time i
thought where is all this stretch going
pixar's location on the doorstep of
silicon valley may have helped it glean
insights into the tech world but the
team had another major advantage when it
came to predicting the future their boss
was steve jobs he was with us for 10
years for half a week every week and
that meant we saw the iphone before
other people did and i remember
picking it up and and using it thinking
it was magic like everybody else did
but i was also going why is this feeling
so familiar
um and i realized oh this is what it's
like when i was used to smoke i used to
smoke to just fill the time like if i
was standing waiting on a corner for a
bus
uh you weren't
feeling awkward and and if you just lit
a cigarette just sort of kept it going
and i thought oh there's some addictive
quality to this
uh that just to occupy my time that is
very very very
uh instinctual
and so again it wasn't a huge leap for
me to go i could see this very quickly
becoming a crutch
of course there's plenty in wally that
hasn't yet come to pass we are after all
still living on earth and it's far more
likely that climate change sends much of
the world into poverty than into space
but life has an uncanny and perhaps
intentional way of imitating art the
ship in wally is called the axiom elon
musk spacex recently took tourists to
the international space station the name
of the rocket
[Applause]
[Music]
you